hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen zieht vorstellungen zwar
wurde mit der sie zugewendet von the
trash lp der band ist es ein sieht wo
man in einem tempel 22 diamanten findet
wir gehen immer einfach auf neuen welt
creative bleib ich hab den ja schon
kopiert der zieht ist 60 38 21 ziemlich
verlesen 603 8 21 45 31 61 606 und 5330
also derzeit steht in der beschreibung
einfach mal kopieren und einfügen
loeding worlds building terrain also es
gibt koordinaten wo man hin fliegen muss
und zwar drückt mir einfach f3 da sehen
wir oben xy usw und wenn wir die
richtung gehen wird ex kleiner und wenn
wir die richtung gehen wird kleiner und
der messen in die richtung hier fliegen
damit wir zum zu dem tempel kommen und
zwar sind die koordinaten x12 sein also
da oben die zahl dieser kleiner wird und
muss 25 sein was das hierfür gebirge
sind weiß ich gar nicht
übrigens das texture pack habe ich
wieder geändert weil das was ich
eigentlich gedacht hatte kam nicht ganz
so gut an
und die haben wir auch schon den tempel
also da ist der tempel und das ungefähre
spawn also fliegt ihr einfach so ein
bisschen ist er hier
ich gehe da dann mal ganz kurz
also ich hab die allgemeinheit überall
noch so eine extreme hills bei um wo er
halt ziemlich viele berge habt woher ich
auch irgendwie hin bauen könnte da so da
haben den lava sie direkt ein oberfläche
viele tiere da ist eine riesige wüste
dass es richtig krank wie groß die ist
und wir gehen jetzt einfach mal rein
machen das hier offen
wir kennen alle tempel gehen runter dann
haben wir hier immens viele diamanten
also sehen schon ich habe die welt ja
mit euch zusammen generiert und hier
sind echt richtig richtig viele sachen
drin also dann kein trash rp ich weiß
nicht ob den schon irgendjemand anderes
vor ihm hatte oder so das muss jetzt
einfach ein oben
das ist einfach immer wieder so witzig
so viel also danke an thrashers ein
medienkrieg gesendet habt ich finde auf
jeden fall genial was alles drin ist
also fünf weisen 14 121 gold 12 und 22
diamanten und das ist eigentlich das
ganze weil 22 diamanten
die kann man direkt einfach alle hier in
sonnen lava naja irgendwann ich hab mir
minecraft beendet ich weiß nicht ob das
city läuft noch irgendwie komisch ich
würde trotzdem sagen das war's von
dieser sieht vorstellung wenn ihr wollt
könnt ihr den wieder einen daumen hoch
gehen wir es euch gefallen hat wenn
nicht dann gebt einfach ein daumen
runter und dann sehen wir uns beim
nächsten mal auch ihr könnt es in die
kommentare schreiben damit ihr
vielleicht beim nächsten mal erwähnt
werden wollt würdet seinen tun kann